first up we've got a colorful fashion
trend anyone can do the wall street
journal reports from the red carpet to
the runway it's all about the head to
toe monochrome that's right you can look
like you just jumped into a can of paint
your favorite color you pick that and
then you assemble accessorize your
playful look by keeping it all in one
range we've got a red mint and orange
with kendall jenner rihanna and j.lo
they're going monochromatic that's how
you do it the guys are on board too a
shade of pink a brown and a mustard on
jake gyllenhall michael b jordan and
jared leto ross would you ever go
monochromatic would i uh you know i do
drew hello you know i like a fashion
risk and i i live in palm springs when
i'm not here in new york and i wear
citron all the time one of the gentlemen
the audience is wearing a citron green
right there you should see me i'll go to
bingo and i wear citron shirts citron
shorts and i have these little citron
slides as well gr you cannot lose me if
you wanted to i was gonna say it sounds
like
like roadside yeah yeah i just stopped
to
dig in a manhole all right well next up
a new a new can of paint can really
change your life it's true and if your
kitchen's looking a bit drab well
experts have got the perfect kitchen
color for you apartment therapy reports
the go-to color for your kitchen is
yellow yellow yeah they say yellow they
say why not start the day nice and
bright design pros say yellow gives
their room a little burst of optimism
and positivity now i love yellow and i i
like color but
yellow in a kitchen i feel like unless
it's butter or a banana it shouldn't be
yellow in the kitchen it just doesn't
work for me there i you know i'm a a
beautiful marigold or mustard is
actually very chic especially with black
instead of going and you do black
soapstone and that sort of mustard
yellow it can and and brass fixtures it
can be very chic i just think you have
to commit and i don't think that i would
necessarily go
too literal in 1950s i would try to go a
little more in the shaker tone or a
little more timeless and i also
recommend everyone ask a friend i
literally send pictures of drew to drew
of my house i'm like help me help me
what should i ask a good friend because
they'll tell you if you're picking the
wrong color i want to be everyone's
personal pinterest board
for design and it's the place i feel the
most confident to play all right our
next color is red oh that's good news
because i'm in all red as in red flags
when you're dating someone new you know
that fluttery feeling you get in your
stomach when you're with someone new
yeah that's the best feeling when it's
when you just met them you know what i
mean you can't wait to see them again
you're kind of nervous all right well
get ready for this the new york post
reports that it could actually be a bad
sign dating coach lauren zoller says
butterflies on dates one and two
good normal fine but if your stomach is
still a flip-flopping around date three
it could be a sign from your nervous
system that something's not right lauren
says that for real intimacy the other
person should feel like it's coming home
it's safe it's settling
lost thoughts okay well this is like i
need to really think about this for
you're just throwing it at me here's the
deal
like when you meet someone you do want
to feel that spark and that energy and
those butterflies but what they said in
the article that you read
she said it should feel like you're
coming home and that's really what it
should feel like when you meet the
person that's right for you i don't know
if you should feel like you're coming
home on date three but no but my date 10
or 12. when i met wellington it felt
like i had known him for years and we
went to lunch we met in the morning went
to lunch that day and we were just
talking i was like have we had this
conversation already and that's what i
mean by coming home where it just feels
so natural that it feels like you never
weren't there already does that make
sense
would you look at me like that well i'm
so happy for you i mean that like
genuinely that's exactly what you
deserve
and it's so exciting to know that you
felt that way
and that's that's that's goals rossi
yeah i know i love that it is goals and
guess what it's my life i know i'm very
very very very grateful and thank you my
love oh hey we got this story it made me
lol a woman who saw a problem and then
covered it in paint this is how you
problem solve newsweek reports brandie
long was sick of hearing complaints from
you know your local your hoa your
homeowners association they always
complain about something well they were
telling her that her shrubs looked dead
so she solved the problem with a can of
green spray paint yes look what she did
she said i don't have a green thumb but
i have a green can of paint
and now her neighbors are they're not
saying anything her neighbors um as we
go to commercial break i would just like
to say to brandy long personally i
love you
[Music]